- I'd like to kindly introduce
deputy director for SOFCOM
focused on acquisition
technology and logistics
Mr. Bill Innes.
(all clapping loudly)
- All right, thanks, Mike.
Thanks everybody.
Good afternoon again.
I think this is where I make a joke
about starting right after lunch.
That was it actually, so
I don't actually have one.
I am Bill Innes
I'm the Deputy Director of
Special Operations Forces
Acquisition Technology and Logistics.
I'll talk a little bit
about what that means
from an authorities perspective,
but my focus will be on
the capabilities themselves
supported by technology that are important
to our Special Operations
forces operators,
which is why we in SOF AT&L exist.
And I'll wrap up with a
few thoughts on threats
and challenges we're wrestling
with SOF AT&L every day.
I'll be hitting the
tech pretty high level.
I'm looking forward to hearing
the experts discuss in more
detail how Tech, AI, ML,
Quantum, Data, for example,
in particular, can help fill
in any gaps and challenges
we see and how we better access it.
So on the next slide point
anywhere probably, huh?
There we go.
Real quick agenda.
I'm gonna start with a video and again,
I'll start with our authorities,
how we're gonna structured
as a bit of a baseline
in SOF AT&L.
Then talk about our processes,
the technology focus areas
that we have in the command
and key capabilities
and programs associated
with those tech focus areas.
Made a few changes to the rollout.
Doesn't follow exactly
that, but close enough.
And I may bring up a few
points as I go through this.
I've kind of taken some notes
through the first half of the discussion.
I really like that that
early part of the discussion,
obviously acquisition
and how fast we move is
always a challenge and
what our requirements are
and legacy programs and moving
on to the next generation's
always tough in DOD acquisition.
I think we're pretty good at it in SOFCOM.
I've done acquisition in a
number of places, Air Force,
Navy, even a little time with the Army,
so I've really enjoyed being in SOF AT&L
so I do think we do it better
there than anywhere else.
So I'm gonna start with the video.
It is about six minutes.
You should see a few things that
I'll come back to in the next few slides.
It's really just one
maritime focused vignette.
We do a number of these and
we could do any number of 'em,
but I think it's pretty
good kind of for this forum
to highlight some of those
areas that, you know,
we'll drive this discussion.
Some of the tech areas we're focused on,
so about six minutes.
- [Instructor] The 2018
National Defense Strategy
articulates that the US military
will face increased global disorder,
characterized by decline in
the long-standing rules-based
international order,
creating a security environment
more complex and volatile
than any experience in recent memory.
The reemergence of long-term
strategic competition,
rapid dispersion of technologies
and new concepts of warfare
and competition that spans the
entire spectrum of conflict
requires a joint force
to meet the challenges
of this reality.
Adversaries anti-access area denial,
A2/AD capabilities aim to
create a broad area maritime
surveillance capability targeting system
and contested Comms environment CCE,
that in time of conflict would
render the existing naval
and joint platform architecture
increasingly vulnerable.
Recognizing the increasingly
complex security environment
the AI for maritime manure futures concept
was designed to employ AI, Edge Compute,
Specialized Communications
and robotic autonomy
in maritime soft man/unmanned teams
in a highly unique manner
to tip the balance of power
in multi-domain A2/80 competition
space to our advantage
today and into the future.
Artificial intelligence for
maritime maneuver addresses
those key problems faced in the
future operating environment
to gain, maintain, and extend access
into the adversary's competition space.
While enabling the joint
forces decision advantage
and the application of scalable effects
with enhanced precision.
Hallmarks of the AIMM
concept, AI enabled SOF,
maritime craft and seasoned
operators, Stealth, deception,
mass and precision are intended
to penetrate the adversarial
defenses, complicate enemy kill
chains and ensure own force,
lethality and survivability.
Future success will
increasingly go to the actor
who can best gather data,
process it into actionable information
and team with partners, both
human and machine in real time.
Maritime SOF with specialized
low observable craft
and focused applications
of AI and autonomy
teamed with multi-domain unmanned systems
can extend its access
swarming from the sea
through the Lal commons in inland
to directly enable
scalable and mass effects
on scene but unseen.
The AIMM concept takes
advantage of cutting-edge
usage of onboard compute,
data, artificial intelligence
and specialized communications
or AI-enabled mission
autonomy in small Uxs
to deploy within range
of adversary targets
enabling AI autonomous systems to detect,
classify and identify IM points
to provide enhanced precision of targeting
to fires platforms enabling
a clear decision advantage.
Critical to the success of these missions
is all domain awareness, alternative PNT,
mission autonomy and tactical
intelligence at the edge
and specialized communications on demand,
while ensuring mission
command deliberately
and discreetly networked
to the joint force.
Given their low observable
small size mission autonomy,
and tactical intelligence at the edge,
AI enabled robotic systems
in maritime SOF man/unmanned teams
are uniquely positioned
to excel in their ability
to gain, maintain, and extend access
into highly contested environments.
An on above and under maritime
SOF sea strike portfolio
of access mass and precision
could provide the joint force
with a broader spectrum of unique options
to create more complex dilemmas
for defeating adversaries.
AIMM expands the maritime
strike Warfare's ability
to achieve kinetic effects on
a broader variety of targets
that might have otherwise
been inaccessible.
AIMM promises to shrink
the competition bubble
in highly contested A2/AD environments
by employing AI enabled
maritime SOF man/unmanned teams
operating far forward in
contested environments
to deliver kinetic and
non-kinetic effects,
including unprecedented access to SUB-T
and mobile launch sites.
Ultimately removing cover and
concealment from our opponents
while providing targeting
quality data to the joint force.
AI for automated target detection,
tracking, cross-cueuing
and command and control
will further expand the ways
in which the maritime
soft man/unmanned team
can enable joint warfare
with speed, precision,
and mass efficiency to support
the effects kill chain.
The artificial intelligence
for maritime maneuver futures
concept leverages maritime
soft capabilities envisioned
to operate in new and
unique ways when empowered
by AI autonomous systems to operate
in maritime SOF man/unmanned teams
to solve critical operational problems
of the future operating environment.
The AI enabled maritime
SOF man/unmanned team
provides a collection of
unique, scalable capabilities
that will enable the joint
force to compete and win
in complex, contested
and denied environments
across the competition continuum.
This is what the nation expects
from special operations.
(bright upbeat music)
- Okay, that is a conceptual
video, if you will,
but a lot of it is in reality
in terms of what we're going after today
and what we're moving dollars to,
we're having a conversation over lunch.
You can follow the dollars, you know,
show me your dollars and I
can show you your strategy
and we're definitely moving
a lot of dollars into that space.
Okay, so organizationally, I
did wanna start off with this
a lot of folks in the room
probably know all about this,
but you know,
I wanted establish the
foundation to capture
where we as an acquisition fit
in the overall organization.
So confounded in 1987
outta the failed Iran
hostage rescue operation,
almost everybody in here knows
that Congress forced the DOD
to establish the joint command
to ensure not we had not only
the best individual service operators,
but the best cross service team.
And that wasn't just
in the operation side,
but also in the acquisition
support side of it as well.
They wanted us to have
the acquisition authority
to get after our joint needs.
There are two sides of
SOFCOM makes it unique in DOD
Ms. Logan talked about it earlier
in terms of the two sides
of SOFCOM on one side's,
the left side here, your left
side is the operational side,
and then on the right side
is the organized training equiped side,
the component commands,
AOC uses soc war com.
Marsac closely aligned to that right side,
but showing here down the middle
is the acquisition authority,
and that's what we in SOF AT&L execute.
By law, we are responsible
to the Commander,
General Fenton with
advocacy from ASD Solic
to deliver soft peculiar
equipment and services
to SOF operators with
congressionally appropriated dollars.
That's really important of course.
We do that in close collaboration
with the components,
with the operators, with the big services,
but primarily through contracts
with the defense industrial base.
So SOF operators need a new capability.
It's SOF AT&L's responsibility
and legal authority to provide it.
So again, just a little bit of a baseline,
and this is who executes that
authority organizationally.
Mr. Smith at the bottom there
is the acquisition executive.
The second and third rows are
the program executive officers
who deliver the capability
in their domain areas
supported by the top row most importantly,
at Ms. Lisa Sanders in the
science and technology shop.
Her work, which includes
close collaboration with labs,
academia, industry, finds and
helps integrate technology.
Our PEOs and ultimately our
operators finds and helps
integrate the technology, our PEOs
and ultimately the operators
need PEOs work on tech two.
But that really is Lisa's 100% focus.
It's akin to the separate,
are now separate acquisition
and sustainment shops
at the OSD level led by Dr. LA Plant
and the research and engineering shop
led by Ms. Heidi's Shoe.
But again, we're still
under one roof at SOFCOM
to our benefit I think.
I wanted to highlight as
well some of the specific
areas that are focused
on in this conversation,
I think is PEO, SOF digital
applications, you know,
strictly focused on SOF
applications, software applications.
We just stood that one up recently.
PEO special reconnaissance
in the middle there,
PEO in the upper left, command control,
communications and
computers, all important.
Of course, PEO maritime, Randy slap,
they work very closely together.
That's one of the challenges
I think as you know,
integration changes I guess
and becomes more important is
tying all the PEOs together
but I think we do that a
pretty good job at SOFCOM.
(clears throat)
I also wanna point out
master chief Steve White
in the bottom left there
he is our Navy Seal
senior enlisted leader.
Really important to have
that operator in the loop
and make sure we maintain
our North star there
that's why we're here to support.
And just to the conversation of the size,
this is about 900 people
and that's 900 of the 6,000
that was mentioned earlier.
So acquisition is unique in that regard.
Like CENTCOM and this joint staff,
they don't have an acquisition shop.
So this is a big piece of that.
I'll tell you that, you know
we've done lot of data runs
on that and the experience that I have,
I'll tell you, we need more
people, (laughing loudly)
I know it was brought up
earlier, but you know,
in terms of the complexity
and the size of the contracts
that we're awarding that we're working on,
we haven't changed that
much in the last 10 years,
but our RDT&E and procurement
dollars have gone up
and it is one of the things
that I lose sleep over is,
is our workforce, our work life balance.
There is a real challenge and
we're in a war for talent,
so it's something we're
constantly working on
or we need a heck of
a lot less bureaucracy
to the point I think that was made
and I think that is increasing as well.
This is the group that
delivers the capability.
Okay.
High level tech pathway process.
The endpoint really is
the block of programs
of record on the right here.
That's really the capability delivery
and we're really part of
the platforms and services,
which is on my last slide is, you know,
it all kind of sum up,
but upfront I wanted
to provide an overview
how we drive tech into those capabilities.
We don't buy tech for tech's sake.
We buy capabilities and the tech
helps us meet those capabilities.
Someone may challenge me on that,
but it was brought up
last night, you know,
tech in terms of like AI,
"Hey, let's just sprinkle some AI on that"
you know, we're still after the capability
and what can tech do to help us
to deliver those capabilities.
And maybe that's something
we need to talk about more
at a higher level.
Again, the discussion that we
had earlier about, you know,
where SOF is moving in
terms of 130s and drones,
you know, MQ1s, MQ9s, you know,
what is next generation, you know,
what is the capability we really need?
The slide is probably
an oversimplification
as generally not linear,
but overall it starts with
the top down direction
from general Fenton and secretary,
me and the guidance documents
all fed by the National
defense strategy up at the top.
And our focus is on the
circle, which I'll highlight,
you know, and, you know,
provides us with those six
technology focus areas,
which I'll highlight in the
next slide in more detail.
But it's also bottoms up
with inputs from the operator
in the field.
Again, critically important
to us, it's who we support.
Not only do they feed us
inputs from our data calls
and cross components as S and T councils,
but if they see something
commercial tech that they like
or maybe more relevant
today in this forum,
something a foreign partner has, you know,
we just came from the Ukraine
discussion round table there
and you know, some of the
things they're doing overseas,
we need to do a better job of
adapting that, adopting that.
And the lessons that
they're learning over there
are enormous.
So we need to stay close to our operators
who are seeing that on
the, on the front line
they have authority but
if the operators see
that they have the authority to try it out
and if it's useful,
we'll fold it into one
of those programs record
and get it to the whole force.
With congressional
appropriations, of course.
Given those focus areas, Lisa
Sanders and her S and T shop
as well as the PEOs execute
strategic engagements
like this one, futures efforts resulting
in the conceptual video
that I showed earlier
to drive thinking on
operational concepts and gaps
and experimentation where
we bring in our partners
to demonstrate current or nascent tech
to see how it might meet our capability
in an operational environment.
And we have two of those
coming up this year actually
in contested Comms and
next generation ISR.
So that's kind of the
cycle that that's the tech,
that analysis S and T type
work that feeds everything
in the upper right in terms of
the programs that we execute.
So these tech focus area.
Breaking them down a little bit further
with a couple of quick
examples we're interested
in biotech such as
repeated blast exposure,
impacts operators next generation,
ISR mentioned that a few times,
including space and cyber,
not just about the drones these days,
although that still is important.
Network and data
management, sensor fusion,
hyper enabled operator,
optical character recognition,
natural language processing
information dominance
if you will, is a big part of that.
Next generation precision
strike loitering munitions
is popular these days, so to speak.
And next generation mobility
including expeditionary
logistic which is a big deal.
Acknowledging these are fairly broad
and there's some overlap.
I'd suggest AI & ML data
computing enhance all of them.
It does give us some
guidance and boundaries
with limited resources and I
think you saw a number of those
if not all in that video.
Especially how all the sensors
and associated Comms and data
would be linked together to
hyper enable our operators
on mobility platforms
employing various effects.
And what do those capability
platforms look like?
Here's a high level
overview, not all inclusive,
we like to say we deliver
everything from satellites
to submarines, which is true.
The slides broken down by domain
capability areas including
the ground, air, and maritime
portfolios on the left,
I did, Colonel, I wanted to
dig into the, not dig into it,
but I'm gonna check my numbers.
I worked on the F22 program
back in 2004, five and six.
I'm pretty sure that was more
expensive than the AC130J
So that what is got my, the F22.
- [Colonel] 165 according to
Wiki, which is never wrong.
(laughing loudly)
- It was over, it was over, well $2,006,
it was over 200 million and
there was always a gimmick
that they pulled where they
didn't include the engine.
So, but anyway, I will look that up,
but it got my attention
having worked on F22
when we went to full rate production.
Anyway, as I noted, you'll
see some of the things
from the video already in our formations.
The combatant craft, the
undersea craft drones,
precision strike munitions.
But very clearly why I think we have gaps
is in the last three rows and
Comms and data particularly.
And that's interesting because
the department is still
fairly decent I think at delivering
purely defense related capabilities.
Some of the hardware defense
related capabilities,
although it probably does cost
too much and take too long.
I think we'd all probably agree with that,
but we still kinda lead, lead the league
so to speak in that.
But we primary leg and
when it comes to areas
that are now driven by
the commercial sector.
So 40 years ago I think we
led in all of these areas,
but now we're just
desperately trying to keep up.
Again Comms data, AR networks
and software in particularly,
we have the hardware in a lot of ways,
but fusing all that data together
and high bandwidth network,
operating congested environments
using AI & ML tools and
high-powered compute,
maybe disconnected from
the broader network
to process the data
and feed the operations
to make the right decisions at speed
in not only kinetic strike scenarios,
but sentiment analysis and
information operations,
information dominance in all
of that put together, you know,
that's the crux of the
challenge that we're facing.
Okay, last slide, Anita.
Really my questions and
final thoughts and a twist.
You know, these are the questions
I'm presenting to the group
and it's really the things
that we wrestle with
every day at SOF AT&L.
I'd be interested in kind of
the panel's thoughts on this.
Final thoughts to consider,
particularly related to
the threats and challenges
inherent these tech key technologies
that support our operators,
supports our capabilities.
First is security, cyber security,
working with non-traditional
DOD commercial providers
in a classified environment.
Higher levels of encryption
required for military products.
We can't just give our operators iPhones,
at least I don't think that we can.
The viability of our encryption tools
in the face of Quantum powered
threats, supply chains,
not just robust supply chains,
but trusted supply chains.
All of these security
concerns are in balance
with the ever-increasing
need for interoperability
and integration with allies and partners,
which we've talked a lot about here today.
And that's key to the
SOFCOM mission always has
and always will be I think
it's almost a perfect
contradiction locking
our capabilities down,
but exporting them to,
or integrating with partners and allies.
Second is how do we keep pace with,
or even get ahead of industry?
I've read estimates
that DOD is less than 1%
of the integrated circuit market
and SOFCOM is 2% of of
the DOD budget higher
if you include the services,
3%, 4%, somewhere in there I think.
Are there paths to
influence to meet our needs,
our security needs, our
defense related uses.
Do we need different business
and financial arrangements
with willing partners?
Congress has improved acquisition,
I think in our ability to keep
up with the commercial sector
with OTAs and MTAs,
you hear these acronyms
about contracting approaches
and acquisition approaches
and that's helped.
But I do think we need to
do better it's not enough
because the threats in the technology
in the commercial sector
is changing so fast.
And third is what risk
are we willing to take
with the AI & ML driven
tools and how we use them.
There's probably a little
risk in using these tools
for sentiment analysis.
We talked a little bit
about hostile environments
we're maintaining our aircraft.
We kind of talked about that for example,
but how far off are we from
really using AI & ML tools
to help us make kinetic decisions
or information operations decisions
or electromagnetic dominance decisions?
How far off are we from using that?
And is our risk risk
calculus that different
than our competitors and enemies?
Almost certainly.
I think the answer is yes there.
So that's how I'll wrap it up.
I'm about to get the hook
actually rather abruptly I guess,
but I'll turn it over to the panel.
This is what we and SOF AT&L do.
We kind of did a quick run through
of our technology focus areas
and what I see is the challenges
and threats against us,
but that's what we do.
Make sure that our operators
have far more capability,
which requires the best
technology than the enemy.
So thank you.
And I don't know if I have
time for questions maybe.
- [Speaker 1] Sure, (indistinct)
Do you have time of questions?
So please, (indistinct).
- [Speaker 2] You know, when drones first
sort of arrived on the scene,
US Air Force was always very
keen to sort of say, you know,
there's always gonna
be a human in the loop.
And when I was watching the video,
I mean that you played, where
will a human be in that loop
given all these unmanned AI driven?
- Yeah, I don't know for sure
that I have the answer to that
like physically where
that individual will be,
whether it's the operator
on the combatant craft
that you saw or you know,
at the operational command level
you know, using our
mission command platform,
which we're building under PEOSDA.
So it's probably a combination of both.
- [Speaker 2] I guess to
clarify when, (clears throat)
there will always be a human in the loop
when the decision is
made to kill somebody,
was the sort of operating
idea that the US Air Force had
is that basically like,
we're just completely past that point
and it's not even worth a discussion or?
- Today I think it is, I
think we're past that point.
- [Speaker 2] Yeah.
- Yeah, yes sir.
- Do you agree with that or
you don't agree with that?
- [Speaker 2] I don't
know enough, but it just,
it seems that we are in a situation
where these machines will
simply be fighting each other
and the humans will be
almost entirely absent.
- I personally think we're
a long way off from that,
but I understand your comment of course.
Yes ma'am.
- [Speaker 3] For those
really cool systems
that you showed in the initial video,
how important will it be to have,
if we're thinking about the
Indo-Pacific access to bases
or places with allies and
partners to do maintenance
or resupply of some of those platforms?
- Yeah, good question.
Depending on how they are being used
and depending on the scenario,
I guess I'm getting a
little out of my lane there,
but you know, as it stands now,
it's not critically important,
but if we have no access
over there, it would
be a pretty big problem
is a short answer.
Does that that make sense?
A really vague kind of answer
to your question though,
I'm afraid.
Yes sir.
- [Speaker 4] Hey Bill,
what are your top five
ongoing program acquisitions?
- In terms of dollars or importance?
- I'll say in terms,
- oh in terms of dollar, whew.
I want to answer that
with our priority programs
and it would be like our mission command,
which I mentioned earlier,
a common operating picture,
it would be counter UAS
is really important to us.
Armed Overwatch you mentioned
it is one of our important
programs and you know,
I'm the acquisition guy,
I get the requirement
and the money and I go execute.
But in the counter-terrorism fight,
which we still have to maintain,
we do believe that is an affordable,
effective way to provide
that armed overwatch
so the bigger force can
go do their big thing
against the great power competition.
What's the next one?
Under C portfolio is really important.
Dry combats, submersibles, the DCSs
and let me think about next one probably
man, that's four that pop into my head.
(indistinct)
Data is huge.
Data's absolutely huge to us,
you know, and I did men...
You know, in the video
they called it AIMM,
but we are working, you know,
it's not that same acronym,
but like I said, in the next few years
we're definitely advancing
the amount of money
we're spending on that very concept.
So that's really important program to us
in the maritime portfolio.
- [Speaker 3] Thank you.
- Yes sir.
- [Speaker 4] Yes sir.
How tied in is SOFCOM with
the venture capital community
when you're looking to find
some of these solutions,
for the requirements that we have?
- Not as close as we would like to be,
but we are putting a
lot of effort into that.
Absolutely putting a
And it's an important, (clears throat)
it's something that General
Entner commander of course
is pushing for actually.
He's had a few sessions with some
of the venture capital
folks that are interested
in doing business with us
down at the headquarters
our softwares platform,
if you've heard of that,
that's our partnership
intermediary agreement
that does a lot of outreach for us.
They're a neutral non-profit that helps us
with outreach with small businesses.
They're also holding regular events now,
as a matter of fact it's ongoing
where they're gonna do the
next iteration of tying
venture capital companies
that wanna do business with,
with DOD and wanna invest in, you know,
these types of companies
with the small businesses
with our requirements.
Talking a lot about what I
just showed up here today.
So it's definitely a growth area,
not where we want to be yet,
but we're pushing hard on that.
It gets a little bit to what I said,
I think we need to do better in terms
of our business arrangements
and financial arrangements.
If we can, you know, tighten that up,
I think that's gonna be
really good for what we do.
- [Instructor] Okay.
Please join me and thank
you Deputy Director Innes.
(all clapping loudly)
(logo whooshing)